AI versus humans in a fishing battle IBM
mq version
9.3.4 and the trust radius 2023 best of
awards all on this episode of IBM Tech
now what's up y'all my name is Ian and I
am back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology do the current generative
AI models have the same deceptive
abilities as the human mind you may
remember that a few episodes ago I spoke
about how cyber criminals were starting
to use generative AI to create more
convincing fishing emails well IBM
security exforce red decided to run a
little research project to see how AI
tools stacked up against their team's
experts with only five simple carefully
selected prompts the xforce red team was
able to trick a generative AI model to
develop highly convincing fishing emails
in just 5 minutes now that's quite a
Time save we consider that it can take
their experts about 16 hours to build
their emails after an intense round of
AB testing the results were clear humans
emerged Victorious but just by a small
margin The Click rate for the AI
generated emails was around 11% while
the click rate for the exforce emails
was
18% the deciding factors humans were
able to use emotional intelligence and
personalization to make the fishing
emails more convincing they were able to
weave narratives and be more precise in
targeting the subject humans may have
narly won this match but AI is
constantly improving as Tech technology
advances we can only expect AI to become
more sophisticated and potentially even
outperform humans one day to learn more
about xforce red in their Project Check
out the link in the description of this
video next up we've got the new feature
launch for IBM mq version
9.3.4 IBM mq provides scalable resilient
and secure connectivity from Mission
critical systems and applications within
and across hybrid and multicloud
environments in particular IBM mq
version 9.3.4 improves resiliency
connectivity and ease of use across
platforms there are a plethora of new
features and capabilities in the new
release including IBM mq token-based
authentication this is a new method for
authentication using tokens which
improve security and centralizes
identity management for Q managers
there's also updates to IBM mq console
like a new overview dashboard that
enables rapid identification and
resolution of issu isues based on key
Health parameters in the mq estate for a
full rundown on all the new features hit
the link
below finally to wrap things up today
we're thrilled to announce that 17 IBM
offerings have secured a placement in
the trust radius 2023 best of awards
list these Awards help direct buyers who
are doing research on new products and
solutions for their business needs
according to the annual buying
disconnect report produced by trust
radius the top five resources buyers are
using are product demos user reviews
prior experience free trials and vendor
websites the takeaway buyers want to
self-service their way through their
buying journey and consult reviews from
their peers along the way a number of
IBM offerings were recognized by the
trust radius best of awards including
IBM instana IBM Watson X assistant and
IBM Z so hit the link below to see the
full list thanks so much for joining me
today for this episode of IBN techn if
you're interested in learning more about
the topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
todate on what's going on in Tech
now